well it's the history as what Dave
Chappelle refers to as the alphabet
people in his recent show is he's
actually he has a very good summary of
what I part what I say in the gay
chapter basically the gays and the
lesbians got together and they didn't
have much in common other than the fight
for lesbian gay bi fact that none of
them were interested in each other yes I
mean it's a really I love the sort of
presentation of the LGBT community
as if like the gays and the lesbians
never meet they have nothing nothing to
say to each other in my opinion my
experience the lesbians all find the
gays ridiculous because they think
they're essentially am sort of silly and
obsessed with sex and lots more and the
gays think the lesbians are kind of
dowdy and boring and that's the I'm not
saying my view of oh no I love the I
love the interplay of the politics is
great so anyway but the point is is that
no one ever talks about this but
basically the elves and the Gees didn't
get on at all really ever and there's
nothing common and then the bees came
along and then nobody quite believed the
bees existed I think there's still a lot
of doubt about that okay yeah well put
it another way most most men who say
they're bisexual women don't then women
women almost never cool with that and
the gays think that's just somebody who
hasn't made their mind up yet and we
were that's right or wrong I'm now gonna
be accused of biphobia all my other many
many crimes but anyhow and then then
then the tea's come along who have
absolutely nothing in common apart from
also some suspicion from wider society
and the teas morphs in the space of a
few decades from dressing up as some
like summer clothing of the opposite sex
to full-on sex changes and this happens
incredibly fast now to this position
where people say there are people who
are born transsexual which is as I say
in the trans chapter it
really fascinating but it's by no means
as clear as that but by the way I also
say that the tea's run against the elves
and the jeans overwhelming well now if a
child is diagnosed with gender dysphoria
which is a really troubling whole
business this 80% of children diagnosed
as having so-called gender this for it
will grow up not to have it
ie they will grow out to be straight or
gay and a lot of gay men and women look
at that and they think oh that could
have happened to my younger self
you know that's or tomboyish lesbian
might have been told actually you're a
boy and we're gonna give you hormone
therapies and block your puberty and
then you can have an experiment you know
medically on you and a bit later and
then I mean that is really there's like
a lot of in totally right there's a lot
of tension pushing people towards the
extremes I brought this up with zubi
that I don't I don't remember the last
time I heard tomboys like there's no
such thing as a butch girl anymore or
like a girl that likes to do sports
there's a future boy trapped inside of a
girl's body and one of the strings think
you see one of the strains think I mean
by LGBT that's a bloody minefield I mean
as I said that's just one great big
contradiction there but it's much worse
when you see what the tea dusts are the
women because women have spent decades
fighting not to be judged according to
male standards among other things and
then when trans comes along people who
were born men say they're women and
quite often do a lot of things and
approximate women in a way that is
highly offensive to women
highly offensive for instance I give an
example in the book of well what one
second why feminists in Britain
described as you know the assumption
that a woman's natural body shape is
that of a sort of Brazilian transsexual
you know all all big breasts and sort of
horny and you know and oh man a lot of
women like that's exactly the kind of
sexual objectification of by men of
women that we were
trying to get away from ya and so anyhow
that all of this the point is all of
this is just a bloody great big mess
it's much messier than everyone pretends
like oh all this interlocks and if we
can tackle trans rights we can also
address women's rights go no they might
go like that like that and just keep
happening like that there was a pro was
an event the other day in the UK there
was a meeting of feminists British
feminists and they were bericht by trans
activists outside the police were
protecting trans activists and these
people who were men until quite recently
a banging on the windows intimidating
the women inside and it's like trans
rights yeah what what are the situation
of the men allowed to intimidate the
women often if the men say they're now
women when they wear heels that's when
they wear heels
yeah that's exactly when they're allowed
unless they take them off and then start
using them as oh yeah this is really
messy and everything in our day says all
of these things are linked and it's
really straightforward and I'm just I'm
I'm kind of pissing on that party in
this book mother yes there's a number of
parties getting pissed on in the book
[Music]